Mitchell: Well,
good morning, everybody.
Welcome to the Geo track
at Google I/O 2011.
Um, I trust you all enjoyed
this morning's keynote.
We have a great lineup
of content for you
over the next two days.
We hope you'll stick with us,
and I'm gonna kick it off today
by talking about connecting
people and places.
Uh, my name is Thor Mitchell.
I'm the product manager
for the Google Maps APIs
based in, uh, Sydney, Australia.
So what I'm gonna talk about
this morning is, firstly,
a little bit about what we mean
when we talk about places
and why they're important,
a little about how Google
connects people with places,
and then move on to focusing on
how you can do the same
in your applications.
So we start at the beginning.
This is Google Maps circa 2005.
Back then, there was
no Street View.
There was no maps, uh, My Maps.
There was no Western Europe,
for that matter.
Um, so...
So it was, uh, it was a nice,
simple world back then.
Um, if you look at the very top,
just, uh, just in
the search box there,
you'll see that there are
only three options--
You've got maps, a local search,
and directions.
Now what's interesting
about this,
compared to, um, what
we're used to now,
is that Maps allows you
to search for addresses,
for geographical entities.
Local search was business
listings and points of interest,
and you had to make
that decision.
You had to choose for yourself.
Um, what am I looking for here?
What type of thing
do I want to find?
Now the thing about that is
it doesn't really map
to the way we just think about
the world around us
on a day-to-day basis.
If I were to say to you,
or if someone was to ask you
right now, where are you?
There are all manner
of different reasonable answers
you could give,
and the answer you chose
would probably be based
on who was asking.
So if it was someone you knew
was already at I/O,
they'd--you would probably just
say, "Oh, I'm in Room 8."
If it was someone you knew
was in San Francisco,
then "Moscone Center."
If it was someone
you knew was abroad,
then "in San Francisco"
would suffice,
and all of these are places,
uh, in their own way,
and all of them are reasonable
answers to this question.
The one thing you're unlikely
to say is the answer
your phone would give you
if asked this question,
or, at least, I would hope
you're unlikely to say that,
'cause I wouldn't be none
the--the wiser if you did.
So what we need to do,
if you want to bring
location-based applications
to mobile devices like these,
that relate to users in the way
they relate to the world--
we need to bridge this divide
between this sort of fuzzy
notion of a place
and the sort of
more geometric model
that, uh, mobile devices use.
Of course, we're sort of
fast and loose
with what we consider
to be a place.
It can be one of many things.
It can be an address.
It can be a city.
It can be a landmark.
It can be a natural feature.
It can be a point of interest.
It can be a business.
It just goes on and on and on,
and you have to kind of
accommodate all that
if you want to make people feel
at home with these applications.
So we recognized this at Google,
uh, some time ago,
and back in September 2009,
we launched Place Pages.
So now every place had a page
where we could aggregate
all the information
that we could find about it,
um, including information that
we sourced from business owners,
information that we sourced
from data providers,
information that we'd crawled
from, uh, sites online.
The next logical step to this
was actually to--to offer Places
as a first-class citizen
within Web Search.
So now you can search for places
directly from Web Search,
and this was something
that was launched last year,
and this is a reflection
of the gradual evolution
of Places as a concept
within Google's product
to being a first-class citizen,
to being an independent entity
coming out from
under the wings, if you like,
of Google Maps.
And that reached
its logical conclusion
with the launch
of the Google Places mobile app.
Now you can just start
from Places.
Um, and Places and Maps
are now peers of each other.
You can move interchangeably
between them.
Of course,
in the developer team,
we realized that places
were important there, too.
And we've built a,
um, a, uh, a popular Maps
developer platform.
We didn't really have
a strong Places story.
So at Google I/O last year,
we introduced
the Google Places API,
and the goal
of the Google Places API
was really to try
and capitalize a--
the development
of a-an ecosystem around--
a developer ecosystem
around Places
in much the same way
that we had done for Maps.
However, we didn't rush into it.
We took it, uh, we took it easy,
uh, and we started just
by talking to developers
to get a better understanding
of what they needed.
We launched a developer preview
back in July,
and we spoke to many,
many developers
about what
their requirements were,
about what the challenges are
in building location-based apps,
and what we needed to do
to meet their needs.
Now it was a hugely
valuable exercise.
We learned an enormous
amount in the process,
um, and we were also
very pleasantly surprised
by the overwhelming response
from developers.
The downside to this was that
there were many developers
who we just couldn't accommodate
in the preview,
so if you were in that bucket,
um, I apologize,
but if you, um,
if you did participate,
we're really grateful for all
the great feedback you provided.
And for the last
six months or so,
the team has been working hard
to try and take
all that feedback,
factor it into the product,
um, and deliver something
that will suit the needs
of as many developers
as possible.
And really, it's the result
of that effort
that I want to present
to you today.
So...
first things first.
No more waiting.
As of the end of today,
the Google Places API will be
available to every developer.
[applause]
And if you were with us
last year,
you'll notice a lot of things
have improved,
a lot of things have changed,
um, and I'm gonna go over some
of that with you right now.
But if you're not familiar
with the Places API,
let's just start
with the basics.
What is the Google Places API?
Well, at its heart,
it's extremely simple.
You give us a location,
you give us an area
around that location,
a-a radius around that location
to search in,
we will give you back
up to 20 places that match,
and these can be addresses.
They could be points
of interest.
They can be businesses.
So to give you an idea
for why this is valuable,
and to illustrate the value
of some of the other features
we're launching,
I'm gonna use an example.
Now I totally
made this example up
for the purposes
of this presentation.
However, I don't doubt
that there are applications out
there that are similar to this,
so if your application's
a bit like this,
I'm sorry.
Um, consider it, a, uh,
consider it flattery.
So let's suppose I like sport.
I love sport.
Not actually
participating in sport.
That's--that's too hard. No.
I like watching sport.
Um, and I prefer to watch sport
with friends
in a bar.
I'd just like to point out--
Comic Sans, always the answer.
Right.
So sports good,
friends good, bar good.
What I'm really looking for here
is to find that awesomeness
that is the combination
of all three.
I'm looking for an app
that will help me,
um, help me find places
that are showing games,
help me meet friends there,
um, generally, uh,
find me that awesomeness,
and so consequently, we'll call
this the AwesomeFinder.
Now there's something--
there's something not right
about this.
It's like a Web 2.0
application, this.
Ah, that's better. Okay.
So as any good product manager
will tell you,
you start out with a product
requirements document.
What do we need?
Well, we need
to find bars nearby
that are showing games
I want to see,
we need a way of sharing
my plans with my friends,
and I want help choosing,
if I've got many options,
which bar will be the best one
for a given game.
Oh, yeah, and then maybe I have
to make some money as well.
So what do I need to do this?
Well, I need the name
and location of bars.
Okay, no problem.
Google Places API
at your service. Sorted.
I'm also gonna need the dates
and times of games,
and I'm gonna need
to match up those games
with the bars
that are showing them.
Now I could go out there
and try and source this
from TV companies
or from business owners,
but I'm just gonna take
the easy option.
I'm gonna crowdsource it.
So this is a photo I took,
uh, just over the weekend,
of a bar literally opposite
the hotel I'm staying at
for Google I/O,
so this happens
all the time, everywhere.
Um, bars advertise what games
they're showing.
I'm not sure
if you can see that.
There's a list of games
at the top.
On the bottom, it says,
"Neighborhood Appreciation Day,
$1 off draft drinks."
So you can get
all your friends together,
you can get drunk, and there
goes the neighborhood.
So...
We want to crowdsource
the collection of games--
of these--these, uh, information
about these sort of listings
and what--what bars
are showing what,
um, so how do you do that?
Well, let's say I'm walking down
the street and I see that sign,
I should be able to go, Hey,
I'm a great lover of this app.
I'm gonna contribute,
and I'm gonna correlate these,
uh, these games with this place.
So the first thing I need to do
is identify the bar I'm at,
and that's where we come
to the check-in.
Now check-in has
kind of become this, uh,
this very common notion
over the last year or so,
um, but it's really
a very simple concept.
It's just a way
of telling an app
the place you're currently
located at,
in order to--for it
to then offer you
you know, opportunities
around that--
sharing it with your friends,
perhaps loyalty offers,
various other things,
but it's cool.
The check-in is very simple,
and you're here--
people talk about, uh, you know,
check-in is over and so forth.
Well, check-in
is just a feature.
Saying that--saying that
the check-in over--
check-in is over is saying
like the log-in is over, right?
So colors are probably not
helping us a great deal here,
but what we have here
is, um, a map,
uh, very nearby, actually,
um, and then in the middle here,
we have our location,
and then there's
a-a circle around it
that is the ambiguity,
if you like,
in my location signal--
the margin of error
that I'm getting
from my location-based device.
So what my phone is saying
is that I am somewhere
within this circle,
which you can barely see,
but it is there.
So what we need to do
to initiate the process
of a check-in
is perform a Places API search
for this point with this radius,
because, essentially, whatever
I need to check into
should be in that area.
In fact, just as a tip,
I would say, if you're building
such an application,
pad a little,
because one of the, uh, one
of the things you might notice
is that this circle sort of
dissects Del Taco just here,
um, but the actual
point feature of a Del Taco
is actually outside the circle,
so, eh, add a little bit
of a margin there.
So what would the flow look like
for this application?
Well, I would get
a list of places.
Um, I'd choose one,
I'd check in,
and then I would be able
to fill in,
uh, the games that are, uh, that
are being shown at that place.
Now the more eagle-eyed of you
will notice
that this looks like
a real application,
and this looks
like a real application,
and this looks something like
I knocked up in a text editor,
and you're not wrong.
In fact, what I've got here,
and what you'll see
in a number of screenshots
over the course
of the next few slides,
is a reference client that
we've built for the Places API--
we've built one for both
Android and iPhone--
um, that just shows you
the--the core features
and gives you somewhere
to start,
and we'll be publishing
the source code for those
as a code sample, um, in the--
in the not-too-distant future.
Okay.
However, if you look at--if you
look at the--the list of places
on this screenshot in detail,
there are some of them
which are clearly
not gonna be showing sport,
for example, Britex Fabrics.
Clearly, when you're looking at
the Google Places application,
the one that we had--
I mentioned earlier,
that you have on your phone,
we have no sense
of what your intent is
in looking for Places,
but in this
particular application,
we know exactly what kind
of things you're looking for.
We know you're gonna be
looking for bars,
so why show anything else?
Well, we can help you there,
because the Places API
now has a catalog
of over 100 different types,
and you can choose one or more
of these types,
and say, I just want to receive
Places of that type.
Now I'm gonna show you
the impact of this.
This is a-a search, uh, nearby
with no type filtering at all,
and you can see
plenty of Places.
No bars, as it happens,
Switch to bars--just bars.
So it's not that type filtering
actually just removes non-bars.
It actually gives you more space
in your results for more bars,
um, and greatly increases
the chances
that the place you need
is gonna be in there.
Okay.
So sometimes, though,
even that won't cut it.
If you happen to be somewhere
where there are just
a lot of bars,
like Austin, for example,
um, you may still find
that it's not--
the Place you need is not
in that set of 20 results,
so you're gonna have to search.
But searching on mobile phones
is a pain,
especially if you're going
from bar to bar
when you're doing it.
So we're gonna try and make that
easy for you, so today,
we're introducing a new feature
for the Places API,
which we call Autocomplete.
Autocomplete is based
on the same technology
that drives the, um, feature
on the Google Maps search--
search, um, field,
which, um, offers predictions
as to the places you're
looking for as you type.
You can now integrate
that same technology
into your mobile applications.
You can choose to say, I just
want you to offer me addresses,
I just want you to offer me
businesses, or--or both,
and you can also give a hint
as to the location of the user,
um, in order to--
to bias the results.
So let's see
how well this works.
This is exactly where we were
a minute ago.
We were somewhere--ooh, sorry.
Back, back.
We were somewhere
not far from here,
um, about here somewhere,
and this is a list of bars,
but let's say I want
to check into Jillian's.
Jillian's is a bar just opposite
the Moscone Center,
if you're not familiar with it.
It's right over the road,
and it's conspicuous by its
absence from these results.
So what I did is I took
the Places API
Autocomplete service,
I gave it, um, this location,
this same location,
based on this map,
and I started typing.
Well, let's see how far
I need to type.
[humming]
One,
two.
Problem solved.
So...
if you still can't find
the Place you need
after you've done that,
the chances are,
we don't have it,
and that does happen sometimes,
because Places data
is continuously changing.
About 20% of Places we see,
um, in our index,
change every year,
and keeping up with changes
in businesses--
businesses opening, closing,
moving, renaming--
is one of the biggest challenges
of managing this kind
of a service,
but your users are out there,
out and about every day,
and they will see new Places
very quickly,
and they will want
to check into them.
In fact, particularly when it
comes to things like bars,
there's a certain, um,
there's a certain cachet
in knowing about
the hot new bars
and being one of
the first people to go there,
so people will start wanting
to check into places
really quickly.
Now it's already possible
for a user to submit new Places
to Google for Google Maps.
They go into a moderation
pipeline, we check they're okay,
um, and assuming they are,
then they'll get published
and everybody will benefit,
and that's great.
The problem with check-in apps
is people want
instant gratification.
They want to be able
to check into a place
as soon as they've added it,
and if they are
unable to do that,
it's more likely that they will
generate more Places,
and then we'll build
this, um, virtual cycle
of adding Places
and checking into Places,
so we need to be able
to support that, too.
So for that reason,
we have a Report service,
and this allows you
to add new places immediately.
So you can submit
a new Place to us,
and that new Place will be
reflected in subsequent searches
made by your application
instantaneously.
Now at the same time,
we will take that Place
and we will moderate it,
and assuming it moderates well,
it will become available
to all applications
using the Places API.
So you don't have to worry
about other apps
spamming your app with Places
that you don't want
or that aren't good,
um, but at the same time,
all those apps
that are generating
good data, good content,
you will benefit
from that use as well.
We also have a Delete service,
obviously, so that you can
crowdsource, if you like,
your, uh, your maintenance
of your--of these Places.
You can, uh, allow your users
to indicate
whether newly added Places
are good or bad,
and you can choose
to delete the ones that,
uh, that it seems your users
don't agree with.
So here's just a quick visual
overview of how this works.
Every Places API application
has its own little
private set of Places
that have been added
by its users.
They get blended in
with your search results
that come from Google Places,
um, and then all those changes
also get passed into moderation
and then ultimately end up
in Google Places,
where they'll appear
not just in the Places API,
but also on Google Maps,
across all the other properties
that Google has
that exposes Places.
Okay, so we're in good shape.
We have, um, we can implement
the check-in.
We can collect that information
about the bars that we need
from users, and the--the games
they're showing.
Um, we can, uh, we can find bars
if they're not showing up
in our initial search.
We can add bars
if they're missing.
So now we can move on
to the next step,
which is, okay,
I'm out and about.
I want to decide where to go.
So just showing you
what games are around
is relatively straightforward.
You have a list
of all the Places
that people have checked into
and associated,
um, associated
upcoming games with,
so you can show those on a map.
You can also encourage people
to check into bars
when they arrive
to watch a game,
not just in order
to add new information
or new games to that bar.
So you can share that
with friends.
You can see where your friends
are watching games.
You can plan ahead.
But it would be good to know,
you know, if I've got
a few choices,
where shall I go?
What would be the most fun?
So what makes a bar fun
when it comes to watching
a big game?
And to a large extent,
it's simply the number
of people there.
You want atmosphere.
You want lots of like-minded
people enjoying the game.
So as a general rule,
for the most part,
the fun of a bar during a game
is a function of the number
of people watching it
that increases until it gets
to a critical point,
where the bar is so full
that you can't actually
reach the bar,
and then it begins
to kind of fall off
until you get to the point
where you can't actually
reach the bathroom,
and then it's no fun at all.
So as long as we can keep
on the left-hand side here,
we'll be in good shape.
For the most part,
in most cases, um, I think
popularity of the bar
would be a good indicator
of how much fun it is
to be there during that game.
So how do you assess that?
Well, you have the check-ins,
and the check-ins are
a reflection of the popularity
of that bar.
You--it's a signal as to
how many people are there,
and check-ins,
generally speaking,
are a great proxy for that,
um, both over short periods
of time and longer ones.
So on the left here,
we have a-a couple of mocks
of the kind of check-in activity
you might expect to see
over the course of a day
at two different venues.
At a coffee shop, you would see,
you know, a morning spike
as everybody gets their hit,
and then, uh, another spike
at lunchtime
that's a little lower,
and then it would
sort of tail off towards the end
of the day.
At the ballpark, you'd expect
to see nothing for days on end,
and then suddenly, there'll be
a massive rush of check-ins
when the game starts,
and then it will die away.
So similarly, we've got
on the right there,
we've actually got a-a heat map
that we generated
based on Hotpot ratings
that were collected in Austin
over the course of a week,
and that also indicates
the--the Places that are
most popular.
This bright sort of patch here
is, uh, 6th Street,
which, if you've ever
been to Austin,
is kind of the--the heart
of the downtown,
um, nightlife area.
Okay, now...
let's take
this ballpark example,
um, just because it's such
an extreme case.
If I am stood
outside the ballpark, at--
let's take the ballpark here,
in San Francisco, AT&T Park.
I'm stood outside the ballpark
at about, you know,
10:00 in the morning.
Am I more likely
to check in there
or the coffee shop next door?
Well, probably the coffee shop.
But if I'm checking in
in the vicinity of the ballpark
right at the beginning of a big
game, it's far more likely
that's actually where I want
to check in,
so we should use those signals.
We should use those signals, um,
not just to measure popularity
but to then influence
the ranking
of the search results
we give you.
So we're also enabling you
to do that.
If you indicate to us
the Places where your users
are checking in,
we will give you app-specific
personalized reranking
of your search results
in real time,
based on the activity
that you're seeing.
Now I want to stress
that the Places API,
like all of our Maps API
Web services,
is developer-authenticated,
so we have no knowledge
of the end user here.
We don't--nor do we ask for it.
Um, this is app-specific ranking
based on anonymous
check-in signals
that you provide us
for this purpose.
Okay, so that's an overview,
and I want to just give you
a-a brief recap,
and if there are, um, two slides
that I want you to take away
with you from this whole talk,
it's this one and the next one.
So four key services--
Search, Reporting,
Check-ins, and Autocomplete.
You'll see there,
100,000 requests per day,
completely free,
to the Search service.
Um, you can filter by name,
and you can also--
so you can filter by type,
but you can also filter by name
in the Search service,
but it doesn't have the
Autocomplete functionality.
That's--that's separate,
and designed deliberately
to be more lightweight,
and real-time,
check-in-based reranking
and delete Places instantly,
and also get the benefit
of all those Places
that are being generated
that get positively moderated.
Second slide--"Key benefits."
So what are--what do we feel
are the strengths of this API?
Well, effectively,
the strengths of this API
are the strengths of Google.
It's comprehensive.
We have, um,
detailed good coverage.
Um, it's accurate.
It's curated. It's moderated.
It's clean.
You won't see
lots of park benches
and "my mate's house" and...
Um, I was, uh, I was at
South by Southwest in Austin,
um, a couple of months ago,
and I was stood in a queue
that ran five blocks
from a party that was sort of
the opening night kickoff
and as I was stood there,
there was a guy
who was using
a location-based check-in app
stood about 10 meters
in front of me.
He was in the process
of adding a Place
for the queue for the party.
I turned to the person
I was with and said,
"This is my data quality
problem, right there."
It's--so it's clean.
It's also fast.
We sort of take that
for granted at Google,
um, that everything
has to be fast.
Um, the Maps APIs are known
for their reliability,
and, crucially, it's global.
This is a-a heat map
of, um, Place locations
that we've served up,
um, and you can see--
if you--when the day
inevitably comes
that you want
to expand your application
outside these borders,
we are ready and waiting.
And there's one more thing--
We have this Web-based Maps API.
You may have heard of it,
and we wouldn't want
to leave it out in the cold,
so we're also launching today
a set of classes in the Maps API
to bring the same services
into the Maps API.
In fact, these services--
the Place Search service
and the Autocomplete service--
were the very services I used
to build the demos
that I showed a moment ago.
Um, so all these features
will be also available
to Web-based applications.
Right, and that's--
that's the overview from me,
and now I'd like to, uh, invite,
uh, a good friend of ours
up to the stage.
Um, so I'll let you
introduce yourself.
This is Seth, and he's gonna
talk a little bit
about how, um, SCVNGR,
um, his company,
has benefited from their use
of the Places API.
Priebatsch: Cool, cool.
Thank you.
[applause]
Priebatsch: And hit number 3.
All right, thank you.
Uh, hi, everyone.
My name's Seth Priebatsch.
I am the Chief Ninja of SCVNGR
and, uh, and I'm on
my last slide already,
so I have to go backwards.
Uh, hold on a sec.
Voilà.
Uh, so I'm just gonna talk
for a couple minutes quickly
about sort of
a real-world use case.
We integrated
with the Google Places API
about five or six months ago
and have had a phenomenal
experience with it,
and so I'm up here to sort of
sing the praises of it
and very realistically tell you
about how we took SCVNGR
from being something
very, very small--
uh, we actually launched
at Google I/O here last year--
uh, to something very, very big,
in large part on the back
of the Google Places API,
letting them do a lot
of heavy lifting for us,
and it's been--it's been
an awesome experience.
So first,
very quick background--
Some of you may
have heard of SCVNGR.
A lot of you probably haven't,
so 30 seconds on,
what is SCVNGR?
SCVNGR is a location-based game,
and it's a very simple game.
You go places, you do these
things called challenges,
quick, fun things
to do at Places,
and you can unlock rewards.
So you can go to a place.
You can check in.
You can snap a photo.
You can leave a comment.
You can also create
your own challenges,
and anyone can build
these challenges,
so sort of our goal is to create
what we call a game layer
on top of the world,
where everyone is both building
and playing this game
at the same time.
And some quick history--
like I mentioned,
we actually launched this
product last year at Google I/O,
um, with 0 users.
You know, you sort of always
have to start with 0.
Six months later, we had
half a million users.
Three months after that,
we had a million users,
and somewhere in that period,
at around the 5-
or 6-month mark,
we switched to
the Google Places API,
um, in large part
to get better data
and to be able to handle
a lot of the load
that we were coming under,
uh, to make SCVNGR perform
fast and seamlessly
for our growing user base.
The Google Places API
is also incredibly reliable,
and one of the things
I want to talk about
is that you can use it to build
a great consumer experience.
We're nearing
a million and a half users
and growth is accelerating
like mad,
but you can also build
a really big business,
a meaningful enterprise business
on top of that.
Uh, we've got
over 3,000 enterprises
building on SCVNGR, from
Coca-Cola to the Smithsonian
to Sony to GameStop,
all the way to the U.S. Navy,
and all of that is relying
on a core Places database,
uh, which is provided
through the Places API
and through Google Places,
and it is reliable,
and it's something
that you can get,
you know, a really big business
and large enterprises
building off of and supporting.
One of the recent examples
of load that we came under
and--and sort of
a beautiful use case
of being able to get the right
data from the Google Places API
was a campaign we ran
with Buffalo Wild Wings,
where, over 6 weeks
at their 700 locations,
180,000 unique people
played SCVNGR, checked in,
did something like
1.2 million challenges,
unlocked rewards,
and we didn't have to add
a single Place to the database.
There were 0 user places added
for that entire campaign.
They were all already there
from the Google Places API.
Huge campaign, very successful,
and something that we,
you know, were able
to kind of provide turnkey,
just adding our, you know,
our unique secret sauce,
the SCVNGR game mechanics,
and building off of
the infrastructure
from Google Places.
So enough background on, uh,
on--on SCVNGR.
Uh, you know, the interesting
thing that we want to talk about
is what Google Places let us do,
and where I really want
to take this is from sort of
the core of what SCVNGR is,
which is our mission.
Our mission was to build
the game layer
on top of the world,
and to do that, we needed
a couple pre-requisites, right?
We needed game mechanics.
Cool, uh, we could
figure that out on our own.
We needed a game platform,
we needed players and builders,
and we needed to be able
to connect them to places.
We needed to be able
to connect them to the world,
and so we went on this big quest
for the world,
and that's the quest that
eventually led us
to Google Places
and to the Places API,
and if you're looking to connect
people to the world,
and, of course here,
by "the world,"
I mean something
a little bit more specific
than just everything
that's around us.
I mean having the knowledge
to connect people
to the places that matter.
You have a couple options.
We thought about
building it ourselves.
We thought about, you know,
asking our users
to create these Places for us,
to crowdsource them,
to scrape it from the Web,
to do whatever we could
to try and get
a good Place database.
We looked at SimpleGeo,
and we spent a lot of time
working with those guys,
and they actually have
some really interesting things
that we're working on,
uh, that they're working on.
We ended up working initially
with GeoAPI when we launched.
We did not launch
with the Google Places API,
and later did
a transition to that.
GeoAPI later became
part of Twitter.
Um, it has now been shut down,
and we actually--
we did the transition
several months before they--
they deprecated the API,
but one of the interesting parts
of doing this transition
is we were sort of
in a unique position
to do some real comparison
between two relatively
full-featured Places databases,
and I'll give some data on what
that looked like afterwards.
Um, and then there's also
the Facebook Places API, which,
if you guys are interested
in location-based services,
you've probably spent
some time looking at.
And the reason why
we ended up transitioning
to the Google Places API
over the Facebook Places API
is that, um, you know,
aside from quality of data
and some other reasons
I'll go through in a second,
one of the big restrictions
on the Facebook Places API
is that to make any requests,
it is all user-authenticated.
Um, and as Thor
was mentioning earlier,
uh, Google Places
is developer-authenticated,
so you can have, a, you know, an
app and you can get the Places
and you can bring them
into your app
and do whatever you want,
and protect user privacy
and enable your users to have
a clean and safe experience.
With the Facebook Places API,
all queries have to be
authenticated by the user,
and that was something that we
just weren't able to implement,
and so we made the decision
about five or six months ago
to transition
to the Google Places API
for, sort of, these five
big reasons.
One is, you know,
breadth of data.
There's a huge amount of data
on the Google Places API.
It's all over--I mean,
it's all over the States.
It's all over the world.
You know, Places that you--
that you want your users
to be able to use your app,
it's there.
There's a tremendous amount
of depth of data.
Most of our activity
happens in big cities,
so we don't just want
lots of data everywhere.
We want the right data. We want
to be able to dig in deep.
We found that
with the Places API.
Quality of data is phenomenal.
If you've got the Place,
you also want to be able
to get the phone number. You
want to be able to get the URL.
You want to have
the right address.
You want to be able to link to
places that might have reviews.
All of that comes standard
with the Places API,
and it's been really valuable
for us.
Speed & reliability
is--is super key.
We've got a lot of people
hitting our servers
all the time.
The Google Places API
returns quickly.
It returns reliably.
We haven't had a single issue,
and we work with lots of APIs,
which are, you know, some are
more reliable than others.
and so we're very happy with
both the speed and reliability
and consistency of all of that,
and also the road map
that Thor and his team
are taking this thing down.
They've started adding
great categorization,
some of the things
they talked about today--
just really interesting
features, which make our jobs,
as location-based app
developers, much, much easier,
enable us to focus
on what we're good at,
the unique component
that we provide.
In our case, game mechanics.
In your case, it might be
enabling you to help, you know,
find your friends at bars,
but focus on what you're good at
and outsource a lot of
the hard work to the Places API,
and so the future improvements
are a key part of it.
And the last slide
I want to sort of go through
is some of the results
we saw for this.
After we did the transition,
we had a 41% decrease in
"frustrated" location queries,
and this concept of
a "frustrated" location query
is one that we developed to try
and figure out how to judge
how our users are interacting
with the Places we've got.
When you load up SCVNGR,
it's gonna show you
Places around you,
and if you find
the place that you want,
you're gonna click on it
immediately.
If you don't, you're gonna
have to either load more
or do a search, or do something
to try and find that Place,
and we define that
as a "frustrated" user,
someone who opened up the app
and did not get
what they want immediately.
And the number of people
who opened up the app
and did get what they want
immediately increased hugely,
and the number of people
who had to actually do
those searches dropped by 41%.
Um, and this is
kind of an abstract term
to keep track of,
a "frustrated" query,
but it's really important
if you're building
a location-based service
that when they open your app,
that the Place they want,
that the Place they're at
is there immediately,
and dropping that frustration
by 41% was huge for us.
Second is that the Places added
per thousand queries
dropped by almost threefold,
and this is how we keep track
of the quality of our database.
You know,
over a thousand queries,
a thousand people opening up
their phone and saying,
"Hey, show me
the places around me."
How many of them
have to actually add a place?
And it dropped from 60 to 22
after we transitioned
to the Places API.
Again, a huge increase
in just basically quality of
interaction for our consumers.
There was a 62% drop in reports
of incorrect Place info.
You know, this Place is here,
but the address is wrong,
the phone is wrong,
the Web site is wrong,
you know, something
about this place is wrong.
It's just a much higher
quality data set,
and something that we've been
able to now help in improving
through some of the things
that Thor mentioned as well.
And, of course, international
expansion comes standard.
We are only U.S.-focused
at the moment,
but when we're ready
to go international,
when you guys are building apps
and are ready
to go international,
obviously, the Google Places API
has huge support for that,
and that's one of the things
that we found
in other location databases--
it's just hard to come by,
so a really, really great asset.
And the final one, which has
just been wonderful for us,
in working with lots
and lots of different APIs--
it's been up all the time.
It's been fast.
It's been reliable.
We haven't had any issues,
and if you're building,
you know, a key part
of your infrastructure,
and if you're building
a location-based app,
you know locations
are as key as it gets.
Having it be up all the time
is really, really critical.
So that's sort of my quick
use case story
on the Google Places API,
and I'll pass it
back to Thor now,
but thank you for your time,
and have fun building
with the API.
[applause]
Mitchell: Thank you, Seth.
Okay.
So that's all well and good.
How do you get started?
So we have a bunch
of documentation
that, uh, that's been posted.
You can go to, uh,
code.google.com,
obviously, is where Google keeps
all its API documentation,
and the Places API
is no exception.
There's separate documentation
for the Places features
I mentioned that are also
coming to the JavaScript API.
If you're not a big fan
of long URLs,
I'm sure your search engine
of choice can help.
If you need to--if you want to
sign up to use the Places API,
you'll need to get
a Google APIs console key.
Now if you've used
any of the existing
Maps API Web services,
um, this will be new to you.
The Google APIs Console
was a service that launched
a couple of months ago,
um, that is a sort of
a dashboard for API use,
all in the manner of APIs
that Google offers.
It's a really nice, tidy way
to look at, uh,
to manage your use
of the service,
to manage your keys, to check
your usage, and so forth.
Um, and then I encourage you
to go to our follow-up session.
As you can tell, this is more of
a broad overview of the service,
and I'm sure many of you
want to get stuck into
the nitty-gritty details.
So the tech lead, the lead
engineer for the Places API,
will be presenting a session
tomorrow at 3:00 P.M.
It's entitled
"Location Based App Development
Using Google APIs,"
and it's essentially
just going right into the,
uh, the thick of using
the Places API.
Okay, so, uh, you'll start
to see these
as you go through I/O sessions.
We have a, uh, feedback pages
set up for every session,
and we'd love to--
to get your thoughts
on how you feel, uh, whether
you feel this was useful.
We also have hash tags for each
of the tracks at I/O this year,
um, so feel free to use those.
And with that,
um, we'll start with Q&A,
and, Seth, you want to join us?
[applause]
Mitchell: [laughs)]
Priebatsch:
[speaking indistinctly]
Mitchell: Yes.
man: So, um, we do a lot
with location-based,
and what we're noticing
is that the young kids--
they're constantly
really excited
about sharing their location,
and I'm seeing,
like, the younger generation,
they're not worried
about privacy as much,
and they're really out there.
Like, me, I want people to know
where I am at all times
so they can always
get in contact with me,
and I'm wondering--
do you see, like, the younger
generations coming up--
they're not worried
about privacy,
they're really out there,
they really want to have
the connectivity,
and just, you know,
just really engaging?
Mitchell: Do you want to--
Priebatsch: Sure.
So I-I think that
what we're starting to see
is--is that, you know,
across all ages
and all demographics
and everything,
people do want
to be connected to places.
You know, when people, um, spent
a lot of time at places,
there are places that they love,
and every different group
has important places they want
to connect--be connected to.
Some people love museums.
Some people like bars.
Some people want
to hang out at malls,
and so we're seeing
a general trend
that more and more people want
to use these types of services,
and I would agree with you
in sort of a broad overview,
that, um, you know, the younger
generations are more bold
about sharing information
into a digital world.
But even then, you still
want to be careful
to, you know, protect privacy,
and I think that in many ways,
some of the things we talked
about earlier,
about being able to proxy that
through a developer key
and then give users control
over--Hey, I do want
to share this data, and I know
who I'm sharing it with,
um, and people will get more
and more comfortable with that
as they get more
and more educated,
but still a valid concern
for lots of people out there.
Mitchell: I also think
it's beholden on us
who work in this industry,
and who are aware
of the consequences
of, you know, privacy leaks
or, um, and the sort of--
just the longevity
of information online,
to protect people not only
from concerns now,
but concerns
they may have later.
So their--their feelings about
privacy may change over time,
so it's important
that we sort of optimize
for, you know, the worst case,
if you like.
man: Loved the talk.
Mitchell: Thank you.
man: Can you talk a little bit
more in detail
about the moderation process
and how Places will eventually
get selected into it or not?
Mitchell: Yeah, um...
yeah, if you could,
that'd be great. [chuckles]
Mitchell: This is
Jen Fitzpatrick,
who's a V.P.
at Google on local.
Fitzpatrick: Hi, everybody. So,
yeah, the moderation process.
Um, so we put a lot of effort
into trying to make sure
that the Places that we,
uh, the Places that we surface
are actually, uh,
legitimate businesses--
are places in the real world,
uh, right?
Um, and so we have
a variety of means
that we use to do
that verification,
um, everything from, sort of
using, you know, using humans
to actually, you know, sort of
verify that the business exists
to, um, sort of corroborating,
you know, sort of other data
from across the Web,
um, and basically looking at
all the signals that we can
to try to essentially
verify that--
that both the existence of
a place, um, is, in fact, real,
um, and that the data that
we have about it is correct.
man: Is there any SLA,
in terms of, like,
you know, if you add a place in
and it is valid,
that within 30 days, you'd
probably see it come in,
or a week, or...
Fitzpatrick: We don't currently
have an official SLA.
We're obviously looking
to make that turnaround
as fast as possible,
but there's not a--
there's not an official SLA
at this point.
man: Thank you.
man: So Places
or location-based services
work great when I'm in
my home country.
But when I am traveling,
the data charges are exorbitant,
like, $20 a megabyte,
and I can't really use
the Places and these apps
when I'm traveling,
and many people do that
for vacations and business.
So we're trying to solve
the problem with an app,
um, and the only way we had--
uh, to have the top Places
made available offline,
that they can synchronize
and take it with them,
uh, for cities,
and the only way we had so far
was to build it ourselves,
and pretty much like what you
had on your list on the top.
So how can this new API help us
automate some of that
and take some of the subset of--
like a Most Popular Places
offline with me
for specific cities
that I'm traveling to?
Mitchell: So the API
as it's currently designed
is certainly very focused on,
um, finding places near a user
at that moment in time.
Um, we don't really have
a model for saying,
um, can I precache
all the Places information
in a certain area,
um, and there are, you know,
some sort of
licensing complexities
around doing that.
We do allow sort of
a limited amount of caching
for performance reasons,
um, and, you know, you can
refresh cache data,
um, but it needs to be--
it needs to be data
that was originally requested
relating to a real user query,
rather than sort of
an offline operation.
So, you know, in truth, I would
say it's not a use case
that we are able
to cater to right now.
man: Okay.
Mitchell: But this is
the kind of feedback
that's very valuable,
so, um, one thing
I should have mentioned
is we do have a, uh,
an issue tracker,
where you can go and report any
concerns you have for the API
but also request features.
man: But in the meantime,
uh, caching that locally
in our own database
and building our own app--
that may not be allowed
by licensing,
and so the only option
is to build our own
popular Places database
for taking it with you?
Mitchell: [chuckles)
Brian sat up there.
Do you have something to say?
man: The answer
is basically yes.
man: All right, thanks.
Thank you.
man: Hi. Um, one of the problems
I run across as a user
is when I go
to check into a Place,
and there's a bunch
of user-created events,
like for when I have
Movies in the Park,
you'll go and you might see
a Movies in the Park.
You might see this park name.
Is there any plans in the future
to separate events from Places
or allow you to check into
an event at a Place,
or, um, without creating
ten different things,
like today, when I checked
into Google I/O,
but it's also
the Moscone Center.
And--and how do you deal
with events at a location?
Mitchell: So the short answer
is yes.
Um, we thought about this
at great length, actually.
I mean, one of the benefits of
the developer preview we've had,
um, and also
looking at, you know,
a lot of the popular sort of
location-based apps out there,
is we can get a very clear sense
of the way people are likely
to use these types of apps
and how that will
impact the service,
and clearly, events, you know,
are a-a big part of that.
One of the--the things
we, um, we toyed with
was, well, is an event
just a type of place?
You know, is it just
a type of place
that has an expiring date on it?
And we decided, ultimately,
that no, it's not.
An event is actually
a property of a place,
and consequently, we needed,
in order to do this right,
we needed sort of
an extra layer of features
on top of
the existing Places API,
where you can attach
events to places,
you can check into events,
and so forth.
So that's something that
we actively planned to do,
but we, um, it's not something
we were able to get done
um, right now, in time.
man: Thank you.
man: So at--you started
your presentation
speaking about the granularity
of search return, uh, results,
talking about Moscone Theater
in San Francisco.
Um, taking that example further,
uh, we're here in Room 8.
If I was to do a search
on Room 8,
you know, it needs to be
in the context
that I'm here at this event,
um, but further to that,
the returned result would be
in this area on Google Maps,
but is there any plans
to take that further,
to perhaps step inside
the building
and demonstrate where we are
or where--where the--
where we should go for Room 8
within this conference?
Mitchell: Do you mean
from a mapping perspective
or from a check-in perspective?
man: Yeah, from--so--
from the mapping perspective,
to visually demonstrate
to the user,
um, or do we--should we build
custom layers
when--when that occurs,
or what's the best practice
for that?
Fitzpatrick: We don't currently
have plans along those lines,
but it's a great idea.
[chuckles]
man: Thank you.
man: I just want to thank you
for releasing the Places API
for us all to use.
It's really great,
and I'm really excited
to see the focus
on Autocomplete.
Um, for--for Web users,
sometimes the easiest way
to bias a search result
for Autocomplete
is to use their I.P. address.
Is that going to be an option
that we--that we can use
to bias, uh, Autocompletes?
Mitchell: Um--
man: And location searches?
Mitchell: Right now,
the service doesn't
automatically support that.
Um, I'm trying to think
whether there is--
I know that we
previously had a, um,
uh, I think Gears--
Google Gears had an I.P.-based
geolocation service,
but I'm not sure whether
we still have that.
Um, no. I'm being told
by more learned minds
than my own that we do not.
I think, in truth, that, uh,
that is the right abstraction.
I'm not sure I would want to put
that specifically into this API.
I think it's more useful
to be able to say,
for a given I.P.,
have the location,
and then you can use that
in many different Places.
So, you know, that's something
that we can look into.
man: Okay, thank you.
man: Is there
a "Natural Features" category?
I'm thinking of a use
in a botanical garden
or arboretum.
Mitchell: Yes, there is.
Yeah. I would--in the interests
of full disclosure,
I would say that it's mostly
large-scale features right now.
Um, you know, uh, parks--
sort of national parks
and volcanoes
and things like that.
but, um, you know, the nature
of the category theme
is that you can add Places
and you can--
any Place that you add,
you can tag with one
of our existing categories,
and you can send--
man: And how would moderation
fit in that category?
Mitchell: You know, I doubt
we had to face that... [laughs]
um, until now, so I'm not sure,
in all honesty.
Um, but, yeah, I-I will--
I'll be interested to see.
[chuckles]
man: Hi, thanks for doin' this.
It was informative.
Um, simple question--
Support for GAPE?
Mitchell: For--
man: Google Apps
for the enterprise.
Mitchell: So this is integrated
into App Engine, or...
man: No, integrated
with signing in
from your enterprise account,
as opposed to GMAIL.
Mitchell: Oh, I see.
So, um, the authentication
scheme we use
is tied into
the Google APIs Console,
so, uh, essentially, the way
the Google APIs Console works,
if you're not familiar with it,
is that when you log in
for the first time,
you can create projects,
um, and each project has a key
associated with it.
And any given project
can have multiple owners,
so you can associate
multiple Google accounts
with a given project, so that
projects don't get orphaned
if one person's,
um, not available.
I'm not actually sure,
um, what the, uh, Google Apps
account integration
into Google APIs Console is,
but it's something I'll be happy
to look into for you.
man: Well, I think my--so--
I'm pretty sure
you can't check in from
an enterprise account today,
so forward--
Mitchell: Sorry, you mean a--
man: Using a latitude,
let's say.
Mitchell: Right.
man: So where's that
on the road map for people
that primarily use Google
from an enterprise perspective?
Mitchell: It's worth--it's worth
me stressing, actually,
that the check-in service
as part of the Places API
is just this anonymous,
um, reranking model.
man: Okay.
Mitchell: It's totally unrelated
to the check-in feature
that's now part of Latitude
and Google Maps.
man: Oh, it's totally separate.
Okay.
Mitchell: Yeah. So, um,
but I know that there--
that there has been,
you know, interest expressed
in, um, enterprise features
for Latitude.
It's not something that I am,
you know, am fully aware of,
but I know there's--
there's interest in it.
So if it would help,
I can probably connect you
with the right people to ask.
man: Okay, thanks. Okay.
man: Uh, related
to the earlier point
that 20% of the Places
in the database,
uh, change every year--
Is there any thought been put
to making the API queriable
from a historical perspective,
so where you would provide
a date as a parameter
and sort of get what was
around at that time?
Fitzpatrick: As far as I know,
it's not something we've, uh,
it's not something
we've looked at.
Mitchell: Yeah,
but I like the idea. [laughs]
So I would say log it
as a feature request.
It's certainly interesting.
man: Okay, I've seen
the premier version of the API.
What are the advantages
of this premier version,
and are there any limitations
to the free version?
Mitchell: So the Google Maps API
in general,
the overall family of products,
has a premier version,
which is an enterprise version,
and Maps API Premier
has a number of advantages,
including broader
licensing rights, for example,
using use on the Internet
or in for-fee applications,
also higher quotas on geocoding
and directions,
and, uh, and elevation.
Um, and right now, however,
the Google Places API is,
uh, although we're now making it
available to everybody,
it's still considered to be
in Google Code Labs,
um, which is sort of
the initial stage
that an API goes through,
where it's still being
developed and evolving,
and we need some flexibility
just to adapt to feedback.
Um, as a general rule,
Labs APIs are not included
in Premier
because enterprise customers
have much stronger
backward compatibility
expectations on an API,
so, um, what
we anticipate happening
is that the Places API
will graduate from Labs
um, you know, in
the not-too-distant future,
once we've, you know,
we're comfortable with it,
it fits everybody's needs,
and then it will be integrated
into Maps API Premier.
Um, and until we get
to that point,
I couldn't say what
the specific benefits will be.
Um, I would imagine that,
at a minimum,
you know, the same licensing,
technical support,
service level agreements,
and so forth, would be,
um, you know, would be
the most likely possibility,
rather than necessarily specific
feature differentiation.
man: But no limitation
on the usage so far?
Mitchell: So currently, the API,
um, allows you to perform
up to 100,000 queries
per day for free.
man: Thinking from a perspective
of emergency response
and/or marketing,
uh, if you can plot a polygon
or put a point with a radius
and get a summary report
about how many people
are connected--
how many--how many bars
do you have,
how many hospitals,
but instead of having them
brought in
as points with a lat long,
individuals,
to summarize the reports,
is it possible, currently,
if, let's say, we bring it
into the Fusion Tables
and then summarize them there
and spit them out?
Mitchell: Um, so just
so I understand,
this was getting an assessment
of a number of businesses
of a given type in a given area?
man: Yeah.
Mitchell: Okay.
man: So either you trace
a polygon, or you put a point
and you put a buffer
around that point,
and you want summaries,
not just a bunch of points.
You want summaries--how many
bars, how many hospitals...
Mitchell: Right.
man: for emergency response
or for marketing purposes.
Mitchell: Sort of density,
essentially.
man: Yeah.
Mitchell: Yeah, so, no,
that's not something
that we have right now,
but, again, it's something
that it sounds like,
you know, we could--
we could consider.
So if you just do a search
for Maps API issue tracker,
you'll see there's
actually a link there
for logging Places API feature
requests specifically,
and, you know, I'm working
to collect those.
And also, I should mention that,
um, you can star
feature requests
to indicate your interest
in them, and then
that ends up ranking them for us
in terms of popularity,
which is something that we take
very seriously.
So I recommend everybody,
in fact,
even if you don't have
an idea in mind,
keep a regular eye on that
and just flag the things
that you find interesting,
and that will
help us prioritize.
Okay, it looks like that's
all the questions we have,
so thanks very much,
everybody, for coming,
and, uh, enjoy
the rest of your I/O.
[applause]